(warm tones resound)
- [Michael] It's important
to understand the struggle
because the truth is we're
always in the struggle.
- [Crew Member] Marker.
(clapperboard claps)
- Cincinnati in the '90s.
It's a hell of a decade,
Cincinnati in the '90s.
- [Man] The very
foundations of our society
are in danger of being burned.
- [Protestor] We're sick
and tired of being abused,
and beaten, and bashed, and killed.
- We refuse to be quiet.
- [Protestors] We are
everywhere, we are everywhere!
- [Man] Homosexuality is
incompatible with military service.
- This is a human rights issue.
- He said, "I have a dream today,"
and when he spoke about
the sons of former slaves
and the sons of former slave owners
he made no distinction
between the straight ones
and the gay ones.
(dramatic instrumental music)
- [Man] What was the impact
as you start to, you know,
find out about sexual
orientation protections in 1992?
Because it wasn't something
that was done with fanfare.
You know, it was--
- Let's tell each other
the truth here though.
I mean really, you wanna talk truth?
There were guys who were
very powerful in Procter,
and only got more
powerful, who didn't want
to give equal right to
the LGBTQ community.
We didn't deserve it.
(soft instrumental music)
- So moving to Cincinnati
was a challenge for me.
I really wanted to help a
city like Cincinnati change,
'cause if I could help Cincinnati
become more LGBTQ
friendly, that can spread.
I wanted to make that change.
I was dedicated to making
that change in the world.
So Cincinnati was my
battle ground. (laughs)
At P&G, sexual orientation was added
to the EEO policy toward the end of '92.
- You know, that was a big
thing for P&G at the time,
given its conservative nature.
- It was a big day.
I read it and couldn't believe it.
I honestly couldn't believe my eyes.
I think I walked out a
second time to re-read it
to make sure it was real.
- There's beginning to be that feeling
of we're gonna be free,
and boy, how wrong we were.
Since it's not like, boom you've got
this anti-discrimination
thing, and now it's gonna be,
you know, Bambi at the still blue lake.
It just doesn't work that way.
- [Man] P&G almost did that.
They almost put sexual
orientation in the policy
as a bit of a legal thing.
- [Susan] That's exactly right.
It wasn't like they were planning
to do anything different
once they got the words in.
There was no program or policy
that I can remember
that went with it, none.
- The initial perception
was that it was a win.
Yeah, but it was not.
- It provided recognition to
employees that we existed.
- It actually got worse during that time.
When I would walk into
the ladies restroom,
most of the people would walk out.
If I sat down at one of
the long lunch tables
they would get up and leave.
- And then at the same time in Cincinnati
you get this referendum
that passed putting in
the so-called Article XII
in the city's constitution.
- Article XII, oh God,
Article XII. (groans)
- [Woman] Issue three
represents discrimination,
and we're not gonna tolerate
discrimination in our community.
- Article XII prevented
protection for gay people
in employment, in housing
within the city of Cincinnati.
- Specifically excluded gay
people as a protected class.
- It seems like you're making
it up because it's so crazy.
It said that city council was disallowed
from passing any legislation
that would protect gay
people from discrimination.
Now, that's not how it was on the ballot.
The people that put it on the
ballot control the language.
They would have this laundry
list of hot-button terms.
You can't create special
rights for gay people.
You can't create quotas.
- Really, having a
house is special rights?
Having a job and not feel
like they could just walk in
and say, we really don't like you.
I actually, once I was
asked to describe to a group
of P&G women from around the
world what it's like to be gay,
what the experience is like.
And the way I described it
was, it is to never know
when you're going to be hunted.
And therefore you always
have to be prepared
that this is the day that somebody decided
that your wellbeing is a
threat to their happiness.
- [Andi] Not only did article XII pass,
but 2/3 of the voters in
Cincinnati voted for it.
- [Delaine] I remember walking
through the halls at P&G
and thinking, the majority
of you voted for this.
You went out of your way to make sure
that I don't feel secure
in my job or my housing.
- I don't know that I was ever
as mad again as I was the day
after article 12 passed,
and I walked in and said,
"I'm going to make change
happen in the halls
"and walls of my employer."
- I started looking for my community,
for LGBTQ people in P&G
who I could relate to.
And I ended up finding the pot lucks.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- Enough of us had kind of
chatted and said hey, you know,
if this is something
that's recognized by P&G,
it's in our equal employment
opportunity policy,
we should feel free to associate
as a group of gay and lesbian employees.
(whistle whistling)
- What happened with
me is I was playing in
a volleyball league that happened
to have Gary Wright in it.
And he said, "I sort of noticed
that you're blatantly out.
"Do you have any interest in
being a part of this group?"
And I'm like, "absolutely."
I mean, it really was part of
my journey even before P&G,
and that I wanted to
continue, of actively working
to create the world I want to live in.
- I had just moved back to
Cincinnati with the family,
and it was difficult.
So I wanted to have the
chance to make a difference.
- Part of what Gary brought
was he could talk his way
around a lot of things.
He was very comfortable with leadership.
He was really good at that subtle stuff.
That was one of his super powers.
So five of us came together
to talk about what we
wanted from the company.
That was the start of
everything was those meetings.
- During that time article
XII emboldened even more
name calling and threats,
like you know, that posturing.
I remember walking with
our director at P&G,
and we had passed a newspaper stand,
and there was a headline
about gays wanting to,
like petitioning to parade
or something like that.
And he said, "Oh my God, those people
"should all just go to an island."
(dramatic instrumental music)
- If you're in the closet
you can't be bringing
all your energy to the
workplace because you're holding
some of that energy to
protect your own identity,
your own sense of safety, I think.
- So the five of us got together.
There was discussion around
the interest of saying hey,
you know, this is great
to have this EEO policy,
but there are actions in the workplace
that we need to address,
and there are further things
that can be done in deploying policy.
First we need an identity.
I mean, we work in a branding
company, let's get serious.
- I started just playing
around with logos and names
so that we could come up with some way
to refer to us that wasn't necessarily
like flashing red lights, the gay group.
- [Andi] So we started calling it GABLE.
- Sort of the idea of the
gable of a house being a roof
and protection and a gathering
place over the people.
So it had a little bit of meaning for us
as a word and a name.
The letters reflected who we wanted to be.
- [Susan] GABLE being formed
in the mid-90s was a big deal,
even for someone like me.
I felt, maybe I'm not
totally alone anymore.
- [Ed] There's a number
of what the company
was beginning to call diversity groups.
You know, women managers,
or African Americans.
- Affinity groups at Procter and Gamble
typically had an ION conference.
And it stands for Inter Office Network.
So that they could
communicate among one another.
- So there was a normal
process for requesting
an ION conference for a group,
so I just filled out the form
and submitted it, and
we got our ION group.
- The ION conference was
really a way of saying
we would be officially recognized.
- We had it all going,
we were cooking with gas.
And then (mimics knife
slicing) just got cut off.
This is an inappropriate
use of company resources.
Based on what?
I mean, the funny thing was
there was no process that existed.
They had to create it to
say no to us, basically.
But that's how it got to be
the significance that it was.
It wasn't that to begin with,
it was just an ION conference.
Everybody was a part of
like 18 ION conferences.
But, I mean that's really
what led us to standing up
and saying we want to
formally ask for these things.
- We want these three things, yeah.
The three requests were
that, first we wanted gay
and lesbian issues included
in diversity training.
The second one was the ION conference.
And then the third one was
domestic partner benefits.
- Domestic partner benefits
was always the core
that held us together.
It was of universal importance to us.
- So what we decided was we'd start
at the very top of the company.
(pages flipping)
We wanted to go to the top HR person.
We sent him a letter and
requested a meeting with him
to talk about what we wanted.
He sent us back a note basically saying,
I don't meet with groups like yours.
I have my direct reports do that.
- Come on now, cut me a break.
(hand knocking on wood)
- What we realized was that he
had just given us permission
to approach every single one
of his direct reports and say,
your boss said we're
supposed to meet with you.
So we wrote LaVelle Bond and said,
we're a group of P&G employees.
We're lesbian, gay, and bisexual.
And we'd like to meet with
you to talk about that.
He wrote back to us and said,
you can meet with my
associate VP, Waldo Jeff.
- I wasn't in that organization a week
before I received a
call from Heidi Bruins.
(phone ringing)
I don't even know where the
bathroom is in this organization
yet and you're already
calling me to begin the battle
in the global world with
sexual orientation (laughs).
(dramatic instrumental music)
- Waldo was there and he was writing
an agenda on the white board
and his hand was shaking.
He was so nervous.
- I really didn't know what to expect.
- He might have been scared
of us that first meeting,
but he listened, and that was
really evident in who he was.
- If you're being discriminated against
I have learned you have to fight back.
I was born in segregated New Orleans.
I have seen exclusion and discrimination
at a very early age.
If gays and lesbians at
P&G are willing to stand up
for themselves and fight for their rights,
I sure know what it's like to do that.
When this young lady, Heidi
Bruins, got in my ear and said,
"Waldo, you know nobody else
is going to advocate for us
"but you," I knew that she was right.
- At P&G the whole idea is
that you're sharing data.
We're all about the data.
- For over 160 years, Procter & Gamble
has been selling its products
to gay and lesbian consumers,
but we haven't talked about it much.
- We did the research, found
out what other companies
were doing, understood
the tax implications
and the costs that they had incurred.
- We would have these binders
that would have a lot of information.
The kinds of questions that people ask.
You know, how much is this gonna
cost, who does this affect,
why should we do this, where
is the justification for it?
Just to help people to make
their decisions in our favor,
to side with us, was the idea.
- It was pretty much a
resistance initially.
One time one of the vice
presidents came into my office
and shut the door, and told
me that he was concerned that
I was beginning to create an
environment in the company
that was immoral and
he would never support,
and that my working with top
management on that had to cease
or he personally was gonna see
to it that I was terminated.
What that incident taught me
was how we use power to bully.
(crowd shouting)
- [Delaine] One of the
objections that we heard
is that you're telling us
about these things that happen
in these far off places.
Gay rights now!
- They don't happen in Cincinnati,
and they don't happen at P&G.
But because of Article
XII they actually did.
So we started collecting people's stories.
(warm electronic music)
- I was so scared that
the powers at be at P&G
would find out I was gay
for like, seven years.
In addition to lying by
omission about my lifestyle,
I actually manufactured
a wedding and a husband.
That, of course, resulted in
a very tangled web of lies.
But my energy was totally
focused on maintaining the lies.
I had ulcers, paranoia, and
a total loss of self-esteem.
- One time they were in the throes
of doing some mandatory training,
and there was a manager,
and he said, "If I ever see any gay people
"I'm just gonna kill 'em."
- I had had an international assignment.
I'd lived for three years in
Manila in the Philippines,
and my partner was there with me.
We had to figure out how to have him
be there living with me.
There was no official accommodation
for a partner at that point in time.
I mean, this was incredibly difficult.
- I was pretty proud of
my family, my three sons
and the life we had built together.
I never felt like my company
recognized my family.
That was the emotional toll.
Financially it was oppressive
because I couldn't get insurance
for two of the three
children and my partner.
We had to purchase insurance outside,
and that was extremely expensive.
Probably $55,000 just in
medical care for my family.
- And so what we did is we sent two people
to meet with every single HR
leader, and whenever they met
with us they were like, oh,
you're like normal people.
You look just like us.
- And then we'd share our stories.
And that was the big thing
that made a difference for so many people.
- You know, it was the
difference between people,
like, I'm agreeing with
this thing over here,
or I'm disagreeing with
this thing over here.
And it would bring it into, I
am looking at a real person.
- So this is where we
went to Charlotte Otto,
and public relations, so that
you could look at it and say
okay, can the company manage
the external communication
of this without getting beat up?
- I think sharing his personal
stories really took it
from the intellectual, this is right
for the business, to, this is
right for our people because
we care about every individual.
Because I got a personal understanding
that took me from observer to advocate.
(warm instrumental music)
- Her role wasn't to say
we should go do this,
her role was to say, I can manage this.
Here was the person in
charge of the function
that was responsible for making sure
that the external
communication wouldn't blow up
in the company's face
saying, we can manage this.
- And at that point we had been working
on this for many, many years.
- It was a very long process.
- Over the course of five years
we had prepared the environment
to be able to accept
another level of thinking.
And at that point we felt
that we were pretty much
ready to move forward.
So we got the company to
vote on same-sex benefits.
It was an overwhelming vote of a yes.
And unfortunately, the
vote was not implemented.
- The answer came back
of a very disappointing,
we won't be leaders.
We will continue to benchmark,
and we will do this mid pack.
That was the exact language
used with this, mid pack.
We felt defeated.
- It became apparent that
through the grapevine,
that they were going to be
offering insurance for pets.
And I thought I was gonna die.
There's no way my company
can make a mistake like that.
To cover pets and not cover children.
(soft instrumental music)
- [Susan] Back then I was
the one senior manager who was out.
There were people who did
a lot more for gay rights
at Procter who really worked
it, worked it so hard.
And I can't say that I did.
I just was trying to stay
alive most of the time.
I wasn't looking for people's approval.
I was just looking for acceptance.
All I want is a level playing field.
Let me do good work and judge me fairly.
(soft instrumental music)
- I remember I got a call from someone
who at that time I didn't know.
And his name was Gary Wright,
and he came to my office
as he said he wanted to do
to talk about a subject of diversity.
And he came and he had a couple of folks
with him who I can hardly remember.
But I certainly remember Gary.
He said, "John, I know you're
very committed to diversity.
"That's obvious to us
all, but you need to know
"that there is a huge outage in the way
"you are approaching
diversity in this company."
Well, that got my attention.
- And what he said he was talking
about was that we were not
recognizing the different
way of life of our employees.
Now, Susan Arnold was
a very important person
to me with the company.
Susan and I had worked together
in different parts of the
soap business for years.
And I never really
thought about her marital
or her personal life one way or the other.
And I really hadn't sat
down with her and had a,
kind of conversation that, who are you,
what's your whole life like?
- Well, there was one
of these dividend days,
and I saw Susan across the
way, and she was sitting there
with two young children and her partner.
It came together for
me in a particular way
because I knew Susan in so
many different dimensions,
but I hadn't seen this.
It was the importance of
recognizing a person's full life
and the importance of
their having a choice
on what that life would be.
- [Susan] A.G. Lafley called,
and he said to me, "Susan,
"I promise you that we are going
"to get domestic partner benefits."
(dramatic electronic music)
- For P&G, and for me, diversity
is a business strategy.
It's not just about doing the right thing,
it's about doing right things right.
And it's about building our business
and our organization for the long-term.
- That that point having
a company like P&G
make a bold statement like
that was incredibly powerful.
- [Susan] When Procter & Gamble did it
it said something, it spoke volumes.
It risked company boycott,
it risked product boycott.
It wasn't, it just wasn't
that they did it right,
they did it right and they did
it in the face of opposition.
- [Dick] Focus on the
Family decided to declare
a nationwide boycott of our products,
and we had to go to the board
because it did impact our business,
and they were supportive.
I mean, they didn't just back down at all.
We may not have been first
to the party, but we have,
I think threw a pretty good party.
- Same-sex partner benefits
gave us the courage
to step out even more,
to take on Article XII.
(stirring instrumental music)
But it's each of those
steps that have given us
a stronger motivation and a stronger voice
to be a positive force of change.
- [Charlotte] Support for the repeal
was the point at which
P&G became more public
about its commitment to equal
treatment for LGBT people.
It was the right thing to do.
- I don't know that
anybody had a master plan
for, let's do this slowly,
and then this slowly,
and this slowly, and keep
that forward momentum.
But what I think it says
is there's a process
we tend to follow, and we
may not get somewhere first,
but we'll get there better
and ultimately it sticks.
- You look at the dramatic change
of the original EEO policy,
you look at the public announcement
of the final domestic partner benefits,
and you have the support for
the repeal of Article XII.
Those three were big changes
over a fairly long period of time.
Maybe over a 12-year period or so.
But they were big
changes, each one of them.
- I think the thing that I'm proud of
is if people don't really
want to think about being gay,
if there's other things that they are,
like a woman scientist,
or just a woman in general
who's like a strong leader,
they get to focus on those things.
That's really the win for
me is that people don't have
to think about it if they don't
want to, and they can focus
on the parts of themselves
that they do want to focus on.
- To hear that GABLE
is 5,000 members strong
and in 54 countries makes me want to cry.
I think back when there were, (chuckles)
there were just six of us.
I don't know that I
ever would have imagined
a day like this would come.
- We look just like you
and we talk just like you,
and we are human just like you.
Really, there's gay and lesbian people
all around you here (laughs).
- This is my poem that I
wrote for my retirement.
As a youngster growing up in
the bowels of the deep South,
I had the passion for equality,
and of course this big, big mouth.
Expected to be treated equal,
equality had such huge appeal.
All I ever really wanted
was a level playing field.
Those of you trying to become
the best that you can be,
use my experience at P&G
as one last gift from me.
Give more than you take,
perform with passion and zeal,
demand excellence and equality,
and a level playing field.
(paper flapping)